en la puerta del sol de madrid bailando
resistentes indígenas un símbolo 500
años después de que méxico fue
conquistado en la manifestación se han
juntado miles de personas que apoyan al
ejército zapatista de liberación
nacional
un movimiento anticolonialista que
antiguamente era armado
justamente en cabeza del cortejo hay un
grupo de 7 zapatistas de viaje a europa
cuentan su difícil historia como
indígenas
[Música]
somos extraños
extranjeros indeseables
inoportunos de los mismos suelos que
fueron cultivados por nuestros
antecesores un símbolo para los
anticolonialistas antes de llegar aquí
los zapatistas han viajado por europa a
través de una gira
poco a poco se han juntado 70 colectivos
simpatizantes de todo el continente
organizan eventos como esa comida
esas dos francesas han viajado con la
gira por francia y españa- es muy
interesante como que compartir
encontrarnos conocernos y encontrar
luchas apoyar luchas luchas contra el
colonialismo el racismo pero también
contra el capitalismo durante ese
concierto los simpatizantes zapatistas
rindieron homenaje a la gira
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para los movimientos de izquierda
europeos el zapatismo aparece más que
nunca como un símbolo idealizado de una
sociedad autogestionada ecologista y
multicultural una visión más matizado en
méjico